a toda india en huelga los agricultores
de toda india reanudaron el lunes lucha
contra las reformas agrícolas celebrando
su primera protesta a escala nacional se
bloquearon carreteras y autopistas de
todo el país y los sindicatos
organizaron concentraciones en las
calles después de 10 meses de
manifestaciones en nueva delhi esperan
que llevar la protesta a todo el país
pueda presionar al gobierno
yo le doy tenemos aún más entusiasmo que
el primer día y nunca lo perderemos al
'billete con un queríamos hacer una
huelga a nivel nacional contra las tres
leyes agrícolas y está saliendo adelante
con éxito
este resurgimiento del movimiento
coincide con el primer aniversario de la
aprobación de unas polémicas leyes en el
parlamento hace un año el gobierno indio
desmanteló las normas agrícolas
permitiendo a los cultivadores vender a
los mercados privados a cualquier precio
el gobierno argumenta que esta medida
modernizaría el sector y ayudaría a los
productores a obtener mejores precios
pero los agricultores afirman ellos que
la de forma erosionaría el mecanismo a
largo plazo que les garantiza un precio
mínimo permitiendo a las grandes
empresas bajar estos precios y por ende
dejándolos en dificultades diez rondas
de conversaciones entre los líderes de
los sindicatos agrícolas y el gobierno
no han conseguido desbloquear la
situación el primer ministro modi
sugirió cambios para estas leyes pero
los agricultores se niegan a ceder
reclamando una derogación total el
sector agrícola indio sustenta a más de
la mitad de los 1.300 millones de
habitantes del país y representa
alrededor del 15 por ciento de su
economía de 2.7 billones de dólares